each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
thank you everybody for coming we were
taking a bet on how many people would
actually would actually show up at the
talk I think I lost I told them five
people will show up and the nature of
this talk is such that it may actually
get me fired because one of the main
things that have witnessed as talking to
a lot of technical computing people high
performance computing people parallel
computing developers is that frankly a
lot of that work gets done on linux
systems right and the situation is such
that people in the community end up with
a windows box somehow and usually see
reasons for like you know why they ended
up with a windows box in this world says
well when I join the office that but
that's what was available or IT forced
me or or we couldn't afford a mac that's
how we ended up with the windows box a
few people say I actually like windows
thank you thank you and and the real
reason is that because it's the best
gaming machine we all know that but we
don't have to say to anybody but how
they actually use it you know i'm a PhD
grad student I'm a faculty or whatever i
use it for outlook powerpoint excel ok
some gaming but the technical and
scientific computing actually is very
little and i want to show you why
actually windows is a decent box for
doing that type of work so if you look
at the general impression you know the
big elephant in the room basically says
that you get the enterprise people in
suits using word and excel and then all
the cool people hacker community and
jeans using windows so and then the
common complaints i've heard from farm
people are generally around the problem
set of like you know I've already
learned i grew up on linux it's hard to
learn windows
the shell command exe from 1982 come on
you got to be kidding me it doesn't have
my editor all the muscle memory that I
had is no longer there it doesn't have
my favorite IDE that I develop in my
compiler I'm so used to my compiler
options and I know exactly which
optimizations it does it doesn't do and
oh if I touch windows it's going to
whack me in and there's this feeling of
our key no we're not open source
friendly so in somewhere everybody's
unhappy and a few people are very
unhappy in the right corner and my hope
is that at the end of this talk to show
you that Windows is actually very easy
to learn it's got pretty darn good
shells now including those from Linux
and supports all the various
environments that you already use on
linux and in summary i hope to make you
smile or at least go from frown to
neutral okay how are we going to do this
I personally come from before Marcus aww
i worked at Sun Microsystems for many
many years and I am too used to my linux
shell so i want to show you how you can
actually put a linux unix veneer over
windows so i shud everything you've
learned everything you invested in you
can still use it on windows very
effectively all the investment in the
tools libraries knowledge muscle memory
it's all transferable and a lot of tools
and codes and libraries that people use
on Linux are now available on Windows
for doing technical and compare and
domain specialist type of work in this
field for scientist and and one of the
other things that are going to talk
about is the fact that you can kick the
tires try windows without using some of
the proprietary features of Windows kind
of kick the tires try it out without
feeling locked in and the way you do
that is usually cross-platform languages
use C++ you stick to the ANSI standard
you use Python use tools like that so
objective is essentially to add to your
toolbox and not really take anything
away from it so at a high level I'm
going to break it down into three
sections things that give you a UNIX
look and feel you can install it on
windows if some of you feel like you're
pretty much on a Linux box
general purpose development environments
these are you know if you're a GCC user
fortran user Intel's compilers whatever
is these are the tools d'harville and
then finally dedicated caste systems
because a lot of people that we deal
with our scientific computing people and
they may use stuff like MATLAB in
Mathematica okay so these are diving in
the first system that i would recommend
people try is cygwin when you install
cygwin it gives you a essentially a
choice of several unix shells such as
bash z shell korn shell whatever your
taste might be and the way it works this
is not taking a unix linux application
and just bringing the binary over this
is the source level environment for
actual development so you can still use
your shells as the installation after
the installation but if you actually
want to port your programs over you have
to have access to the source and of
course it gives you GCC and a bunch of
other compilers and you can build the
environment so what happens is once
you've built your application there's a
cygwin dll that essentially is the
library that you link to and it does the
translations to equivalent windows AP is
some of the big applications that I've
imported with that you know open office
I mean that's that's a major application
and some of the sun java environments
i'm beyond just having the linux tools
they also have a number of integrations
with windows such as ackles access
control lists and things like that the
next environment that i would suggest
people look at is soua which is a
subsystem for unix applications this is
actually from microsoft it pretty much
works like cygwin the only difference is
while cygwin is a dll a standard user
mode dll that your application links to
sewer is a full subsystem that this is
the windows and T sub system os to from
way back when and sewer they're right
next to each other so while cygwin that
would have to do user mode kernel mode
transition
a lot of this stuff happens at a lower
level and it's more efficient but
generally gives you the same tools same
environment the last one like I said
there's about five six of these I'm just
going to mention three of them just you
get an idea MKS toolkit is another
company that provides a set of well
built and tested unix utilities and
shells but the thing that it has going
for it is a lot of good integration with
windows this is particularly good if
like let's say you're a grad student in
charge of you've been demoted to take
care of the linux and windows machines
in the office and you want to use the
same same utilities to actually manage
all systems so they have a lot of
investment in system administration
stuff beyond the usual shells and
editors and such so as I mentioned the
as far as the basic stuff that gives you
a Linux you look and feel you can use
the various shells that come with these
environments that I just mentioned
another option is hey if you're not
going to do a lot of development and you
don't want a full system all you want is
your grip and arc and said and blah blah
blah blah you can actually install the
new win utilities and it just gives you
about 150 to 200 tools such that you
feel right at home on windows as if
you're on your linux box moving beyond
shells and utilities another thing that
has to do a lot with muscle memory and
it's like i do not want to learn yet
another windows editor notepad or this
or whatever all the interesting editors
that are out there are fully natively
available on Windows and they were quite
well so V I've in Emacs whichever
religion you have they're available in
there there's a bunch of newer batch
that do some new tricks that they're
worth trying microsoft visual studio
environment itself if you go to add in
manager in the tools option and search
for them and
Lynn and emacs there are packages that
install and give you a very decent
emulation of Emax and Linux and VI so
even if you want to be in visual studio
but I still want to have all the
keystroke bindings that you want that
you have learned you can do that as well
so so let's actually look at what one of
these environments looks like so if you
go to add/remove just to show you how
easy it is to do this if you click on
the turn on can you everybody read that
again turn on Windows Features I was
just talking to one of the Microsoft
employees and even he didn't know that
we had this feature so don't feel very
bad if you go down a few you will see
here subsystem for unix applications all
you have to do is click that and after
two minutes you have a pretty decent
environment with several shells editors
GCC 150 to 200 tools and so on
that so any of the environments that I
mentioned will give you all the standard
tools and and and most of them work
pretty decently the sewer one I
mentioned just because it's already on
your system you just have to click and
it works well it also has pretty darn
good integration with the windows for
system administration world as well um
so so the idea was that you just don't
feel like if you thought you've got
linux on windows but you want to see
what does windows add that actually
might be interesting as well so the
improvement to command exe from 1765
that was first written is PowerShell so
this is the new microsoft shell you can
say let's say what was the file get
content is kind of like cat you just
dumped a file the difference between
PowerShell and the unix shells are unix
shells normally just work on textual
items you pump lines into different
stages of a pipe and then some human
readable output device at the end of it
potentially the PowerShell difference is
that is actually deals with objects what
do I mean so looking at this program I
can pump it to get member i can actually
fully type these in and these are all
the methods and properties that can be
applied to these objects that are coming
across which happened to be lines but
this could be programs this could be
complex files this could be a
spreadsheet for example so let's say
let's say i want to sort that file i
could do something like get content pipe
it to get member and let's say you want
to sort it grab minus I length let's see
if there's such a thing and we see yeah
there's three couple of methods and a
property one of them is called length by
the way I did something interesting here
this group actually was not part of
power shown this came from the Linux
tools that are installed earlier so you
can actually mix and
match whatever you need for a better
experience of this stuff together so so
here in this case I will go ahead and
see that we have a length I will send it
to the sort program dollar underscore
gives you the current object and there
it is sorted by length so so it's very
easy to actually mix and match what you
need if you're doing a lot of generic
stuff you can use the Linux tools if
you're doing something more window is
you can drop into powershell and use
powershell to use it for what it's very
good at actually one more thing i was
going to show you since we're here so
remember i said it works beyond just
textual so if you can actually deal with
objects a lot so you might be a
scientific computing guy or a researcher
does a lot of stuff gathers data perhaps
on linux boxes then you want to bring it
in and you want to analyze it in Excel
because the model that somebody else
give you runs in Excel this I'm going to
show you how to actually script this
stuff using Excel so let's say you say
you object by the way tab completion for
all the methods and things are available
as well let's say create a
excel.application so II now holds a
handle essentially to an Excel object
what what does that really matter so I
go pump the Excel object in to get
member and show me what is God and hear
the name member type and definition is
the entire Excel object model at the
command shell level this is beyond just
pumping lines of text around you can
actually do you know stuff like stuff
data into the excel sheet bring stuff
out add a chart to it so whatever your
particular program exposes you can
actually show it so let's make the Excel
visible so somewhere in here I should
have an excel pop-up and here it is and
we see this blank which is pretty
useless so let's add a workbook to it
let's see if there's a add method or
maybe a worksheet workbook method great
and let's see what methods and
properties it has ADD that's a good one
let's hit that oh here it is we've got a
sheet and notice there are three sheets
so let's let's see if we can add a sheet
of our own that has an ADD method to if
I added a couple of times we see that we
got a bunch more sheet so essentially it
allows you to do manipulation of objects
very very easily let's add something as
an active cell i believe is the current
and we see that cartagena has appeared
up here so pumping data in taking data
out manipulating objects beyond a single
line of text the stuff that powershell
is particularly good at okay so now
let's go back to our presentation bottom
line is you've got several choices for
giving your windows box a UNIX look and
feel and there are things in windows
they can combine with it for a better
experience so now that I've set up my
environment I feel comfortable in it I
don't have much of a learning curve then
next obstacle that I see a lot of taking
computing people and academics
specifically complain about is the lack
of their favorite IDE the top ideas you
know this is based on my experience are
usually eclipse something like a Python
environment maybe sage math visual
studio and an our environment I picked
these five and they're all available on
Windows they work well quality ports or
direct implementations eclipse basically
started as a Java environment and now I
support C++ and Fortran number of others
works well on Windows Linux and Mac so
if you want to stick to an environment
that's available all three if that works
for your great ipython I'll talk about a
little bit more later but it's a rebel a
read edit print loop environment
enhanced editor experience and it's got
some parallel computing features as well
sage math works with ipython works in a
web and it's very good for symbolic math
work visual studio is like a Swiss Army
environment for writing native and
dotnet code and there are several our
environments you can get the plane
ar-ar-ar is another language that
there's another dynamic language that
people use especially for stats work
very strong stance libraries and a
company company called revolution
analytics they actually put a plug in
into Visual Studio that supports the
language supports debugging
visualization and everything it's a very
nice port and it says of course emacs
Emacs as we know
can be programmed to do anything so if
you love Emacs you can stick your
whatever compiler you like in there and
it works great so this was the ides if
you're an IDE type person some people
might say hey I'm not really an ID guy
all I needs my shell VI make and I'm
good to go so the build environments the
the MKS cygwin sua and Sarah that I
mentioned they all have a complete set
of compilers and tools for building
stuff another one I would recommend
people look at is Ming GW Ming w is an
environment that's different than the
others in that they've taken GCC
modified it such that it generates
Windows binaries that link to the
windows and c++ runtime so these are
complete windows self-contained binaries
it's interesting if again you want to
stick to GCC but you don't want to go
through any of these emulation layers of
any kind and you want to have a genuine
NT binary so Ming W and it goes you to
do that up to now was just 32 bit we're
helping them actually make a 64-bit port
to Windows another important thing is i
would highly recommend that you stick to
cross platform compilers this would be
again GCC's of the world it would be
Intel C++ and Fortran PGI fujitsu etc
that have the tools that work well on
all the operating systems scripting make
and make all of those stuff again are
available on Windows one of the ones
that I recommend people look at is see
make see make is unique there's an
example of a syntax up here in that yes
you have to learn a new syntax but once
you learn it is pretty configurable and
with the push of a button you can have
it generate a visual studio project file
you can have it generate the Linux make
file you can have it for any operating
system any any particular derivation so
it makes life easy like you might be a
again researcher that have some windows
people they have some Linux users and
you don't really want to constantly
update to separate build environments
see make is good for that all right so
we've got our environment we got our
editor etc etc what about languages and
compilers kind of like VI and emacs the
classics for technical computing or C++
and Fortran so the companies again I
would highly recommend you stick to our
Intel and PGI when it comes to raw
number crunching Fortran still is the
king although not many new graduates
learn Fortran it is usually forced upon
them because of realities of life but it
turns out that for a pure number
crunching Fortran is still the king so
if you do a lot of that stuff consider
Intel or PG ice compiler and of course
C++ you've got several choices there
newer on the block and I would put this
into either dynamic or the more
productive more modern languages it's
things like c-sharp Java Python are F
sharp by the way if you're here for the
demos tomorrow make sure you go to
Kristof's F sharp presentation it's
going to be pretty good and of course
the dedicated caste systems there matlab
Mathematica maple etc that we'll talk
about shortly so you've got your editor
you got your environment you've got your
compiler you got your languages the next
step is libraries you know programs
don't just compile by themselves right
usually they call into a library of some
sort so I'm not going to list them
because there's too many of them but
Kiki ones like boost and numpy and sigh
pilots that are all available on Windows
a lot of this stuff or open source and
freely available so it's there's a very
easy way to get them and use them the
high for high performance computing you
know MKL imsl nag libraries visual
numerics at last etc are all available
on Windows work identically to their
environment and Linux so you should be
very easy to port your programs that
depend on these libraries runtime
libraries that allow you to do parallel
computing things like open and P and P
aye khuda for GPGPU programming again
these are
available in the Microsoft compiler in
all the Intel and PGI compilers and for
CUDA you know NVIDIA has the latest best
drivers available and they've got a very
good plug in into Visual Studio for
doing debugging and profiling and for
data management libraries there's plenty
of those as well netcdf hd5 hdf5 readers
and writers all right so I've got my
editor my shells my compilers my
language is now I build it and nothing
works I need to debug it after I debug
it it doesn't run very fast i need to
profile it etc all the ones that i
mentioned that work with visual studio
come with a native debugger and a
profiler graphical profiler you can show
you this is exactly the hot function
they but usually both have cell IP
sampling and code injection at the
routine level types of profiling there's
a there is a free and open-source plugin
for python that gives you MPI profiling
and debugging if you need to do trade
let's say you've got a cluster of 128
nodes with InfiniBand and their major
traffic going on and some nodes are
always late you want to find out what's
going on if you've used dtrace on
solaris the equivalent of that on
windows is called ECW event racing for
Windows you run that you get a standard
OTF file open trace format file it's an
open standard and you pump it into
something like vampyre or jump shot and
it gives you graphs like this that
basically give you processor versus time
and you can see the communication
patterns you can zoom into slices and
every send or receive that was done you
can figure out what's going on you have
high-level views that basically say how
much time was spent in your application
versus the communication library so you
can figure out where to focus and there
are other things like marmont and isp
where they trap MPI library calls and
analyze it for errors for format issues
for parameter mismatches and so on
alright so so so far this was generic
programming you might be C++ when I
before
might be Python and so on other
environments or integrated development
environments for engineers and
scientists are things like maple matlab
Mathematica and so on all of these again
these are the windows ports I think
mostly when those sports I just did
screenshots so maple symbolic execution
environment matlab more matrix e but
they are encroaching and both in fact i
think maple used to be a plug-in that
was available for matlab for doing their
symbolic work mathematical mostly
symbolic very popular with physicists
and sage uses ipython to give you a
web-based very nice environment for the
ink symbolic math say this mostly for
math ipython a generic Python
environment and octave is in again open
source free all the stuff is open source
and free version of matlab it doesn't
have all the bells and whistles of
matlab but if you can't afford you know
five thousand ten thousand dollars an
environment you can use a octave with a
reasonable success these people these
are all freely available these are
commercial the ones that have a little
star next to them have the added feature
that they work with windows HBC so if
you have a particular job that runs for
many many hours or maybe days or weeks
you can just install windows HPC and
press a button and it knows how to
distribute it particularly
embarrassingly parallel stuff okay all
right so so this was so far a tour of
everything that was important to a
developer domain programmer domain
specialist that can from the look and
feel of Linux to all the programs i need
to all the development environments i
need i can set up my machine and do some
work so if you do actually set up your
machine beyond outlook and excel these
are some of the things that we recommend
they actually look at that are on the
windows site that i think would it would
enhance your experience visual studio F
sharp the language things libraries like
MPI net python and powershell there's
many more but I
just pick those for the sake of brevity
and time vs I'll summarize it as saying
it's a state-of-the-art development
environment I've used pretty much all
the major ones and i still think vs is
one of the best ones out there in fact
when i was working at san marcos system
we had this dirty secret that in my
group which was the compiler
optimization group i would get bills for
the marker soft environment and said
what's going on here so why engineers
would basically say well you know it's
much easier and productive to work in
that environment to build a compiler and
then we'll compile it with the Sun OS
compilers you know the sauna which
compiles were very slow the debugger you
know very slow it's gotten better over
the years but back in the 90s the good
days of Sun I kept getting built for
Marcus on visual c++ it's a very
productive environment you know
intellisense etc etc and more
importantly for hardcore technical
computing power computing people the
major vendors all have native plug-ins
for visual studio with debuggers and
profilers basically this just makes you
do your project in a shorter time which
is critical time to market time to
release time to release your papers is
critical it's beyond just like a nice to
have thing it's important to note that
essentially if you're an academic you
can get this stuff for practically free
if you're a startup of some sort you can
go to the bits park program and get
essentially all the importance of the
marks or provides for free f sharp I
won't say much about it but basically
it's a functional program multi-paradigm
programming language runs on top of net
but it runs on mac OS on linux as well
thanks to mono miguel de causes a
project it's open source is free one of
the things i would check out christophe
will you be doing units of measure demo
okay so okay yeah so go to Christoph
demo he might show that all right
another one that I think is very
interesting for scientific computing
type people is Python it's gone from
being like number 22 on the funky tio
index to being number three it's become
very popular mainly because it's very
easy to learn as a cs101 language all
the way to doing your PhD thesis in
amazingly deep and wide set of libraries
for whatever domain you might be in bio
finance whatever and in this environment
essentially gives visual studio a matlab
looking feel so actually at this point
actually i might demo that let's see if
my connection back to redmond is still
up I've been fired already they work
very fast okay so so the way you get
this let me go to
so you go to court plex which is the
open source environment and you go to
downloads and and press install takes
less than a minute and you're good to go
this is what it looks like
okay here i have the you know standard
editor for visual studio you have a
shell that might be any version of
python you might like get intelligence
on everything let's actually let's do it
here say from as soon as i hit that by
the way this might look a little
sluggish is actually pretty fast but i'm
on a remote login from sis import so as
soon as i hit the spacebar you can see
all this stuff again this is a free
open-source plugin it's pi standard
Python does not lock you in in any way
but the bringing together of a standard
language and the capabilities that
visual studio gives you just makes you a
much more productive Python programmer
so this program in particular is an MPI
program for computing pie and it's kind
of like a hello world of pie so the way
I'm going to actually connect this to a
cluster and actually do some computing
is look at let's look at the properties
first so you've got several debuggers
that are available with this environment
standard Python debugger you got an MPI
debugger hear the name of my cluster is
called Leighton it actually goes to the
Active Directory finds out all the
clusters I have gets the information
about the machines are available in this
case there's about six or seven notes I
can count and I can actually select
which nodes I want my program to be
debugged on maybe because those have GP
GPUs and I'm using pi CUDA or whatever
in this case let's just go ahead and use
everything that there is then I can go
back to my program and i have a
breakpoint set up here and essentially
all i have to do and let's look at and
this is the HPC job manager that shows
you what jobs are running on the cluster
I can't read that
okay great so I'm going to just hit f5
and it says i have an error excellent
what did i do to it oh yes i don't
really need this hitting f5 if you
notice in this window it's submitting a
job to the i don't know if you can read
that but basically says jobs submitted
to the cluster let's see if we believe
it here is the NPI debugging session has
been started okay and here i am in my
program and i can hover over variables
and expand them and look at their data
the fields in the structure as if this
was a c++ program again this is a free
open-source plugin but because of the
features and the ability to paralyze on
a cluster that the the windows
environment gives you it just makes it
that much more productive the rank which
is for spm d programs the most important
thing you want to keep track of if i hit
f5 if you notice the rank is changing
723 and the and the arrow here is is
moving around as each of the ranks hits
that particular break point so i keep
hitting f5 keep hitting f5 and it
finishes and i didn't capture the output
but i think we calculated PI to be
somewhere between three to four I'm not
sure exactly so that was a quick example
of how you can marry some of the open
source stuff and enhance them in the
windows environment
another environment that I want to
highly recommend people to use let's say
okay visual studio is nice I've got a
bunch of plugins but I don't want to use
visual studio for whatever reason I
wanted to stick some environment that's
identical across everything for Python i
would highly recommend you use ipython
which is an enhanced shell that it also
happens to have parallel computing
features whereby you start engines on
different nodes on a cluster and you
connect to it and interactively submit
jobs or do a map of a function across
multiple nodes it has support for
Windows hpc for PBS for a bunch of Linux
schedulers as well and it's obviously
open source available on all three
platforms okay I'm a Python fan I'm not
going to preach too much about it but I
think as being a lot of academics here
you know used to be a time where people
taught visual basic or something as the
first programming language I highly
recommend you consider Python the tools
are great the libraries are great the
develop that the ecosystem is very
vibrant we are a big Python sponsor and
I think the language has a lot of good
things going for it in the future and by
the way the environment that I showed
with visual studio works with any Python
environment it could be ironpython which
is the dotnet version of Python it works
with C Python which is the native
version of Python or JSON pipe I
whatever else other interesting things I
was going to quickly talk about is like
again if you're a dot net programmer you
want to do so hype some high performance
stuff there are things like MPI net
which are rapper libraries
high-performance rapid libraries for mpi
libraries if you wanted to let they have
a program that asked all the hosts all
the nodes in a cluster what is your name
get the names sort them and print them
this is what the C code would look like
of course you can read it but half of it
is memory allocation and you know could
+1
errors and so on the same thing using MP
is C sharp and mpi net looks like that
you get a communicator you do a column
that gather of the environment and
processor names well you allocate that
and then if your rank is zero which
means you're the first instance you do
an array of sort of the host names and
print it out that's how easy it should
be this one you can even tell what the
program is doing until you go and throw
everything else out the way the MPI done
it by the way gets his high performance
is that unlike the JVM dotnet allows you
to do a bunch of tricks like unsafe code
code code unsafe do a fix such that you
stick a handle to a particular area in
memory and tell the GC not to move it
and then if it happens to be one of the
standard MPI types you just go ahead and
does a peon VOC into the MPI send the
native MPI send otherwise it serializes
like in the Java wrappers for mpi
everything gets serialize blindly as a
result for the famous net pie
performance you can see that C and C
sharp essentially have identical
performance behaviors because for most
native types all it does check and call
the native environment anyway so let's
see you have drank the kool-aid and
you've come to windows and you say okay
what else does windows have show me very
quickly how I can learn it I would
recommend a project called parallel
Dwarfs again open source project that
teaches you how to do parallel
programming with every language small
medium data types large data formats and
any particular runtime environment what
code we took well they took the dwarfs
from Phil kalilas environment a paper
that basically has all the standard core
algorithms for hpc embedded you know the
spec benchmark machine learning etc and
they paralyzed every version of this
using a OpenMP using MPI using this
using that and so essentially for each
native and managed environment for each
of these programming models for each of
these data sizes run it you run the
program you trace it you plot it and you
show results this is good for teaching
this is good for analysis of mixing
stuff together and this is for example a
structured grid project and at the end
you get results of what the runtime
behaviors were like you also get
detailed trace information that you can
analyze see what the cache behavior was
etcetera etcetera and so jump shot and
vampyre have already mentioned high
resolution InfiniBand type performance
performance between nodes traced and
clock corrected between processes so so
far it's been mostly on-premise local
cluster local paralyzation for this part
of the last part of the talk how much
time do we have perfect I want to
actually ask my colleague Philippe ahora
to come up and help me out wanna
introduce yourself
my name is Philippe hora I work in the
windowless species every group we put
their basic whatz hpc pack windows
server together with his pc pack is what
we call the windows XP see server sweet
and hpc pack basically allows you to run
a computational problems in parallel and
like we're going to show actually even
on the cloud very very easily and the
first thing I remember you said is you
wanted to be at the beach all in all
here in car back here yes yes preferably
so yeah so I would love to have a laptop
that's connected to cloud and runs all
my stuff over there so I don't have to
have a million-dollar cluster around so
so let me tell you what my problem is
I'm going to act this out I'm a science
I'm an astronomer and we've got a bunch
of star telescope data that comes in and
we want to we want to do some
improvements to the images these images
come and they're very patchy they have
seams and there's actually a lot of
correction and prep that needs to go
into these images we can do it on a
local box it just takes forever we're
talking months in weeks or months so we
want to see how you could help us do it
out on the cloud so I can take my laptop
to the beach and connect it to a jury
can you help me actually we can
excellent so let me show you what my
problem is the beach no I found a beach
let's find a famous star area horsehead
nebula everybody knows the Horsehead
Nebula this is by the way worldwide
telescope okay so when we get all these
data from different telescopes this is
how they come in if you can see it's a
different color it's not what the color
the ICS is God scenes is very patchy and
what we really want to do is do the
processing that allows us to turn that
image which there will be millions of
them into this which is what the
actually if you look at through a
telescope that's what you see so there's
a lot of image processing raw image
processing matrix operations and so on
so I know with our team has given your
team that
and if you could just show us how we can
paralyze this and run it on a cloud that
would be great all right so and we see
that our cloud has moved up here
all right so show us how it works okay
I've talked with a few of you and I know
you some of you use hpc pack but this is
me basically the main console that's the
administration console and when Sean
said he wanted to run a very very big
job I immediately thought about the
cloud what i prepared for you sean is
basically 40 notes up on the cloud extra
large nose eight cores each for a grant
or 320 cores well this was surprisingly
easy to put together so where's my head
mode in this your head node is the only
thing that's on premise and that could
be a laptop that's exactly what I'm
going to be demonstrating tomorrow in
this case it's it's the head know that
you have in redmond right yeah okay so
so can you show me like a pictorial view
of this stuff that is the beauty of it
we aside from the normal list view where
you can do a lot of the actions to to
manage we have fully customizable heat
maps in this case what I've chosen for
you is to performance counters at the
top you see cpu utilization which of
course being idled very minimal and this
throughput so the nice thing about it is
that you can customize the colors and
the performance counters and these are
pretty much the basic so this is kind of
like ganglia very much like angular I
understand gang okay okay so now as we
said 320 course the nice thing about it
is if you look on this side you can
group them so we're not just looking at
your astra knows you can also have notes
on site in this case you don't because
you want to run these big job on the
cloud but I could have my laptop four
nodes locally test my application and
every month when the telescope data
comes in I can press a magic button and
it goes to the class zactly or you could
start running it to make sure it's going
in the right direction okay you like it
you burst to the club and it's
surprisingly easy for example we were
looking at the nose here to add a node
you just go ad node select the windows
azure node click Next and just select
the number of nodes you need there's a
very quick initial configuration to give
the data about your astro subscription
but that's it so it's very very easy to
unknown so as far as my
program is concerned is it is it
transparent to it that some nodes are
local some nodes are in the cloud or do
I have to change my programming style
transparent okay so you just talk to the
scheduler yes that's that's what hpc PHP
CPAC that's for you basically it has a
scheduler and some deployment tools to
fur and how do i sir bring those up and
down that's a beauty too let's say you
don't want to run it in all of them at
the same time you just select a bunch of
notes we're very bad actors I can talk
about yeah I thought we were doing and
just way more drama bigger well let's
say you're having a beer okay and you
just want to write in a few of them you
just take them off long okay so I just
click on takeoff lifeline and they'll be
kind does that mean it sure takes them
away or they just they're just not
available for scheduled in their step up
and running on now what if I wanted to
give them way or that's the shutdown or
yeah if you're stopping you would click
stop and then you would take them all
away okay okay so let's let's run the
program see if it actually works so to
make it even easier and to make sure
that these them i would go quickly we
put it on the script so ready to write a
script sure okay so let's see the heat
map because yes that's what i want to
show you to the proof that it's working
so data is coming down from the cloud
down to the server that we have in
redmond and as you're going to see start
the performance counters start gathering
information from those notes app in the
cloud and firing up of course if you
utilizations the first thing we see so
there's the proof we made it work I
haven't seen anything changed where's
the proof
they're the same colors to me this
here's the drama they keep changing
trust me oh ok ok regular yeah ok all
right yeah we've all realized the
refresh rate for it not to be too costly
when it goes up and I see I see ok
excellent ok well thank you very much
this fantastic thank you excelente and
if you want to see this in person come
see me both number 13 tomorrow excellent
Thank You Philippa all right we'll let
that run and I'll quickly try and finish
all right so we talked about this
already
so I'll kind of conclude by saying
having been in the UNIX and Linux world
still using them and living in the
windows world these are the things that
in my humble opinion are worth checking
out such that you can combine them
together for stronger toolbox as a
scientific computing person I think
Visual Studio despite some of the
learning curve is worth it get the vim
get the emac simulation stick to a
standard language if you want to be a
little bit more brave C sharp and F
sharp or excellent highly productive
languages for scientists things like MPI
done it that i mentioned GP GPUs
obviously for this kind of for this
general zip code are highly highly
useful the best drivers the best
development environments such as insight
are available on Windows if you're doing
any scientific Python work visual studio
is a fantastic environment for it the
cast products such as matlab Mathematica
etc that I mentioned the primary markets
that they sell to our windows so usually
the best ports are their domain
specialist support in general if you
want to do some scientific stuff with
things like even Excel there's lots of
support for you lots of add-ins even the
windows HPC product you can give it an
excel sheet and say run and it runs it
on a cluster for you in a in a
parametric sweep or Monte Carlo style if
you have a UDF a user-defined function
in your Excel that does number crunching
you can tell the HPC system say hey from
Excel say this is UDF is HPC safe you
sends it to the cluster and you can use
so a style calculations for it I think
the intel on pga compilers again
environments work best on windows
because of the visual studio integration
and dotnet in general if you're a JVM
user I think net is it's got some
features that are well ahead of a JVM
and even think things like generics are
done better and you have more control
over the what behavior of the VMS so in
conclusion if you haven't already and
you're a technical scientific computing
type person give your windows box some
love I think it will be surprised what
cool things you
find in there beyond just excel and
outlook you know you can you leverage
all the investments you've already made
muscle memory know how 20 or 30 years of
using Linux all that stuff transfers
over very easily and my advice is stick
to the cross-platform languages when
you're kicking the tire and you can
enjoy the experience without feeling it
locked in and it's not really a
trademark I made that up and this best
features of linux and windows in my
opinion and that's how I work and it
works for me I hope you'll give it a try
that's it we have time for a few
questions
thank you very much it was an excellent
presentation and particularly interested
in this offloading HPC to Azure how does
that work if your application or your
NPR I application you're running anyway
is dependent on large volumes of data so
so very good question he will say how do
you do the data problem with on-site
off-site so first of all as far as the
bursting support in the latest version
there's three ways you can actually use
things one is the standard cluster
that's traditional clustered locally you
can also take a button even if you don't
want to invest in a bunch of clusters
you can take a bunch of windows boxes
wrote them and say I want these 50
machines that are sitting at night idle
to be my cluster so you can do an ad hoc
cluster very easily and you can also say
I want to go into ashore and get my 300
nodes so you can add the maximum you can
have a local cluster bunch of
workstations that nobody uses at night
and is your for like the most complex
environment currently the NPI stuff
that's in beta internally works purely
in the cloud right there upgrading
ashore to have high speed networks for
mpi style programs such that you can
have dedicated clusters and for that
obviously you don't want to have a lot
of data going up and down you pre
populate your data in the azure storage
and then you go ahead and say go up
there but ideally you want to have a
tiny cluster or some of those windows
boxes that i mentioned to try it on for
eight and then by induction it should
work on 64 128 it never does but you can
at least start debugging
no more question so thank you very much
again for a very good presentation thank
you